hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to a long
time ago a young filmmaker named George
Lucas helped create a parallel dimension
in a galaxy far far away it's a strange
world bizarre aliens and unbelievable
creatures a world that the sci-fi
community will never ever forget ok the
punchline is Howard the Duck for all the
strange things that George Lucas has
done whether it be bad unnecessary or
just outright racist nothing compares to
the weird cinematic bond that he
actually made the strange choice of
producing Howard the Duck if you think
Jar Jar Binks was bad
he still is but this is a creation that
equally matches that theatrical travesty
so what came George Lucas the idea to
attach his name to such a goofy movie
well maybe the comic book had something
to do with it that's right
this was actually based on a Marvel
comic book by the same name it was about
a duck who came from a parallel
dimension where everybody's a duck but
somehow got zapped into our reality they
have a ton of strange adventures yeah
sounds like a blockbuster to me too
let's take a look so we see Howard in
his parallel world where he lives in an
apartment of in jokes he sits around
drinking beers smoking cigars and
reading the latest edition of play
doctor
you know a kid's movie look at this
thing it looks like donald duck's
missing nephew drunky Thanks so yeah he
lives in probably the stupidest of
parallel dimensions where every single
person is a duck it's like a bad episode
of Twilight Zone that accidentally began
with the twist ending alright so Howard
sitting there watching TV when suddenly
oh no it's a quick don't you mean a
quack is chair stress to shake and
Rumble as she's propelled backwards
through his apartment building
flying through dozens and dozens of
walls until we see it can't be that
cannot be real
that cannot be real is there any way
we're viewing the rest of the movie I
mean you know I'm not going to be able
to top that I don't care if your runs
into Jar Jar Binks the Care Bears and
Fonzie from Happy Days there is no way
in hell that I am going to beat doesn't
woo I mean what is the point you're
making a kid's film starring a cute
little ducky and you start out with now
kids are you mad what cleaning
everything out I mean this movie is
rated PG right
this is considered PG material are you
seriously telling me that showing female
breasts is wrong but showing Daisy's
knockers isn't going to cause any
psychological damage I think the people
who rated this movie had psychological
damage I mean hello so yeah after you
try to repress that memory Howard
continues to fly out of his apartment
actually in this space suddenly this
guy's voice takes over and tries to tell
us why the cosmos come plus words upon
words in these galaxies is every
possible reality exists what is what was
and what will be start here with the
words
in the beginning there was power the doc
Wow all the coolness in the narrator's
boys seemed to be magically sucked out
just by the mentioning of the title
that's usually a good sign so Howard
somehow crosses dimensions and ends up
in the terrifying land of the human
world but not just the human world the
human world of the eighties ah he comes
across this woman who's being attacked
and he decides to help her out
look no one laughs at a master of quack
fool all right the obvious show show of
anti quack doh but we'll let it slide
every ducks got his limit no more mr.
nice duck this is obviously no place for
an intelligent duck yeah um just to
check uh how many more puns are there
going to be we simply insert the word
duck in the common everyday phrase it's
okay I'm just gonna have this on standby
I hope you don't mind so after being
bailed out by a doc boy that's got to be
embarrassing we learned that the young
woman's name is Beverly and as you can
imagine they both have some interesting
questions for each other where am I
Cleveland Cleveland uh-huh that's a
perfect weird name for this planet
planet no no that's the city the planets
called Earth I think Earth I think yeah
um just to check this uh idiotic wape
isn't going to play any major part in
this movie by any chance is she okay
bottoms up so Beverly is about to leave
poor Howard behind of the awkward 80s
love music suggests that she should do
something else to change
I'll go to whenever me go to it it can't
be any worse than that time you let that
singing giraffe sleep on your couch you
consider that progress so being a sucker
for our hard duck case beverly decides
to take howard in and let him spend the
night a nice place you pay to live here
it's cheap the manager my band found a
pony I suggest you find a new manager
hey I'd love to but we got this damn
contract with the soy you know you're
talking to a duck right so Howard
eventually falls asleep as Beverly
partakes in a rather uncomfortable
sequence
hmm mrs. duck I guess I kinda like it
what am I gonna do with you
well roasted or extra crispy comes to
mind
so they go to a scientist played by Tim
Robbins to see if he can figure out
where Howard came from and how he got
here
nice ducky me Phil you Howard so he
obviously doesn't help much
which means Howard is still stuck in the
surreal world where he'll never seem to
fit in I'm a freak an outcast Oh beat it
I thought he was cute at first but then
he went as video so he came to
everything he also tells Beckley to go
away as he just wants to be left alone
that's the way you want it and so long
ducky don't shed any tears over me torch
you come along in your self-pity
metaphor mars women are from venus ducks
are from some parallel dimension where
apparently they have duck tits and Oshea
uh if you can believe in how it actually
gets a job cleaning up at a local
romantic spa because nothing says
romance like a feathered alien cleaning
up your love juice it's really
disgusting look at this you gets thrown
in the hot tub and the couple just keeps
making out what was that oh it's just
some small fully clothed animal morphic
life-form swimming in our hot tub Oh
despite the job how it seems to still
not be fitting in as crowds of people
constantly seem to remind it
that's a duck man that's a duck dance a
toy that's a desk that's a dope a dope
at Bombay
so how it returns to Beverly who happens
to have a band called Cherry Bomb I
understand the bomb part of the cherry
section throws me off there he comes
across Beverly's manager and tries to
persuade him to let her out of the fans
contract is this gonna be easy
or is this gonna be trouble
whoa I think this duck means business
they pick him up and throw them across
the bar thinking they got rhythm but
then
hell I'll get my ass kicked my palm
trees so after that embarrassing display
the manager decides to give the women
back their money and let them out of the
contract
so Howard meets up with Beverly
backstage Claire no not this guy again
Howard did the movie just run out of
dialog that wasn't a sentence as a sound
effect that's like the skirt was written
by Gerald Lee pulling boy I don't know
what that is what the hell is he doing
there anyway well he and run out of soda
got back together wait he's dating one
of the singers I don't know who's more
desperate for dates you or me I guess I
have a soft spot for unattractive
unromantic unpopular and all-around
unlikable people well no sex now I'm
working so even though we got out of the
contract the band is still stuck without
a manager maybe you should be on manager
wait a sec no I think you'd be a great
manager no maybe you're just the kind of
bizarro influence we need oh yeah
with him as their manager their band
will finally be taken seriously but
unfortunately that's not all they talk
about just can't seem to find the right
man maybe it's not a man you should be
looking for
you think I might find happiness in the
animal kingdom ducky
like they say thou love strange we could
always give it a try
oh I'm sorry the door was hoping oh
thank god those three angels of mercy
happened to be scientists who think they
know what brought Howard here apparently
they were working on some sort of dine
mentionable jumper thingy that pointed
into Howard's universe and accidentally
brought into our world so the easy
solution is just to send him back
through the same process so the
scientists decide to drive into the
machine and send him back right now
you're the one and only Singh that's
making it very hard for me to leave oh
so the gang gets to the machine with no
problems or dilemmas along the way and
it looks like Howard is finally going
home well that wasn't so bad I mean it
certainly wasn't a good movie but I can
definitely say that I've seen work what
was that it explode again it was
terrible we have no right to tamper with
the universe does this mean the Ducks
not going home we lost control again and
there was another explosion
we brought Howard down the first time
but what if we brought down something
else this time
something that could possibly make this
film go on even longer yeah sure so yeah
the movie keeps on going as apparently
one of the scientists is taken over by
an alien life-form from another parallel
dimension I'm not getting any more
transformers on this country I am now
someone else my god he's transformed
into Cobra Commander soon my dark
overlord willing and elf yeah excellent
they haven't spotted us
get out of that kitchen cow bra attack
so the characters I guess just sit and
talk for a bit while the scientist
continues to reenact seals from The
Exorcist I am now on the dock or Lords
of the universe and your mother sucks
cocks in hell on top of it he can also
use his mental powers to do horrible
menacing things like assassinate table
condiments my powers are growing next I
will destroy the Tabasco sauce yeah to
make things worse
Howard gets into yet another fight when
all the truckers at the diner's start to
insulted well gee he threw a pie at the
other guys surely he's not gonna throw a
pie you know they keep fighting until
they finally grab him and put him in
this place so what we gonna do like beat
him up toss him around a bit or tie him
down and trying to decapitate him dude
what the truckers become homicidal
maniacs
but the belching Skeletor gets up and
saves Howard so he can get the key to
the dimensional machine back sounds like
a bunch of bull the odd thing is that
even after people leave he just keeps
blowing shit off I guess he just has a
real hate for food condiments and
kitchen utensils that dinner flatware
must die
so the scientists kidnapped Beverly
decides to take her away because because
why are you kidnapping her anyway yeah
that's why I thought on the way there
that alien side him needs to recharge
his energy he does it by taking out the
cigarette lighter and doing this
I got nothing to say I think the scene
speaks for itself
meanwhile our meets up with Tim Robbins
as they just so happen to find a plane
figure out how to fly it and use it to
say Beverly I can't believe a movie
about a nerdy Tim Robbins and an alcohol
talking that could be so implausible
it's like a bad trip meanwhile the alien
makes it back to the laboratory after
getting rid of some pests cops
smog inspection I never do my mother he
ties down Beverly hoping to transfer
another alien into her body as Robinson
Howard come in to save the day
Beverly gives them some helpful advice I
really hope she dies so after the
scientist transforms into Albert
Einstein's heroin addict cousin
Howie rushes at him with a laser gun and
blows everything up of course they go
through the scene where they think he's
dead but he wakes up and everything
seems to be okay
so this has gotta be the end of the
movie right No
yes still wanna make it a little
stupider okay why don't we have the
alien mutate into something ray every
house it would throw up and have Howard
run at it with the laser gun again whoo
but there's more Harryhausen vomit
coming through the portal what do we do
machine hour you gotta destroy it blast
it oh-ho or don't huh never get home
yes let the monster slowly kill us and
eat us alive knowing that at least the
machine will be okay to take you back
why are you still waiting for doctors
join a damn thing and then we get the
scene where we think Howard is dead gee
it's almost as good it's the first time
yet dad I am NOT Howard Eddie oh oh good
he's possessed does that mean we could
kill him oh it was just a joke ha ha ha
hilarious
so everybody returns home I guess Howard
is their new manager I'm hoping he only
speaks via telephone and at the end he
even has his own guitar solo oh yeah you
will believe a Duncan Rock I also
believe that a Duncan bow this is the
worst thing that George Lucas has ever
made sense anything not Star Wars or
Indiana Jones related and even bad he's
slowly trying to destroy apart from
being silly stupid and surprisingly
boring this film is just plain
mean-spirited everything is shot in the
dark someone's always trying to kill him
or hurt him it's just a thoroughly
unpleasant movie but hey look on the
bright side it could be worse no no I
can't actually this is the worst if you
have a chance to pass up the stuff suck
I suggest you drop it like the rotten
egg that this stink bomb was born up
just remember kids quack is wack I'm a
nostalgic minute guy remember it so you
don't have to duck tant's woo